good morning Hank it's Thursday it's my
last video of pizza mmus and I'm wearing
a suit which can only mean one thing
that it's time for the Bank of
nerdfighteria semi-annual report the
last semi-annual report was a year and a
half ago but it's 2018 words don't mean
anything let's talk about money right so
nerdfighteria has a charity called the
foundation to decrease worldsuck which
despite its silly name is a real charity
devoted to trying to decrease the
overall level of suck in the world and
the foundation raises money all year
long in anticipation of our big annual
charity event the project for awesome
this year the foundation has about fifty
thousand dollars in the bank going into
the p4a some of this came from Amazon
smiles some from people's workplace
Giving programs a bunch came from tab
for a Cause which lets you raise money
for charity while you browse the web and
also half of the revenue from this
YouTube channel goes to the foundation
so thank you for watching ads and/or
subscribing to whatever YouTube red is
currently called Plus this year every
pizza miss purchase supports the
foundation which reminds me that all
this Pizza miss magic will only be
available for one more day at dftba.com
so get it while it's hot and buy hot I
mean available but on that front you may
notice in the coming months that more of
our work inside of nerdfighteria is
transitioning towards supporting charity
like our pizza miss royalties are going
to the foundation the proceeds from
life's library the book club rosianna
and I are starting go to partners in
health this is happening for two reasons
first because Hank and I do not need
money we both have jobs that pay well my
job being having written a book seven
years ago that became quite popular and
Hanks job being having 40 jobs and
secondly we feel like it makes sense for
the revenue generated by nerdfighteria
to be spent in ways that are in keeping
with the values of nerdfighteria
honestly I've always felt kind of guilty
getting paid for pizza John t-shirts I
think there are better ways to spend
that money and so we're gonna spend it
better but and this is the last thing
I'll say about it I want to emphasize
that it is far more generous for a
person with ten dollars to donate one
dollar to a cause they care about than
for a person with a million dollars to
donate a hundred thousand dollars to a
cause they care about it's really easy
for rich people to seem altruistic and
we're making this transition because we
can afford to okay back to the video so
the $50,000 we currently have in the
bank will be a great start to the
twelfth annual project for awesome which
will begin this year at noon Eastern
Time on December 7th there
the first half of the project for
awesome will be raising money for
pre-selected Charities Save the Children
and Partners in Health two highly
effective organizations that we've been
working with for over a decade and then
during the second half we'll be raising
money for charities chosen by
nerdfighteria since 2012 the project for
awesome has raised over seven and a half
million dollars for charities supporting
causes from cancer research to clean
water initiatives and I'm really excited
for this you're speaking of which if you
can think of any perks that might tempt
your donation dollars let me know in
comments this year Hank and I will match
all donations to the first half of the
project for awesome up to one hundred
and fifty thousand dollars and every
year there are a few people who are able
to add to that matching fund which is
amazing if you somehow are able to
donate a thousand dollars or more to
this year's project for awesome please
email us at Hank and John at gmail.com
with matching in the subject line your
donations are tax-deductible and you
will be profusely thanked but of course
we know that most people aren't in a
position to do that and regardless of
whether you can donate you can make a
project for awesome video in support of
a charity you care about people can then
vote for your video and the charity
might receive a grant from the
foundation so get started thinking about
your p4a videos it's only 29 days away
last thing I should mention that the
life's library book club is closing
enrollment tomorrow because we are
running out of spots links as always in
the doobly-doo below Hank thank you for
a fun pizza miss I probably won't get to
say this again until next beets in this
so I'm going to enjoy saying it now I
will see you tomorrow